and it's a different hero every night
[Applause]
falling away shot is good Packer
everywhere 22 at both ends another 14.8
rebound from pharmacy at the Bourbon
trail
[Applause]
then the game is time answer taemin
Tipton urban comes up with it
watch out here open to the land bank
shot separately
zip glass as good as any just watch this
one just laid it up there easily and he
gets off the blends instead of perfectly
earlier ball in the magician with the
ball off off the blast
instead of perfectly earlier call him a
magician with the ball I salon right
who's a good young defender got his
hands full right now roving trying to
spin makes him take a tough shot he
still knocks it down
[Applause]
Irving gets in the paint
TT rounds at home he's got 35 like the
match of dad Leonard on them but then
he's got a watch with a switch
Irving's in the room left-handed backs
at home one per game and he accepts the
pressure of the moment to make the big
shot serve it to the rim off the glass
does it again
at 6'5 play ball and challenge the shot
nearly stolen
Irving shaken back to the ramp accent
again I'm driving on the right side and
this is just good basketball here right
[Applause]
pull-up jumper masterpiece tonight here
in overtime
[Applause]